but it's funny because my wife came in
excited to it and she said listen
there's some lady who had a baby and
then she had menopause depression and
this and that so I gave up zoloft and
this that this is that also she started
smoking weed now she writes a blog yeah
potty mommy or something like that
potty mommy some Studio City or
something
she got a read her stuff she hit so I'm
gonna check it out my wife has the name
at that house I kind of want to go and
like have I've heard that you can go and
like tell them what's wrong with you and
they'll tell you what kind of weed to
buy for your issue is poison you know
how to do that I can really see we'll
sell this in the morning
so as you wake up yeah after you drink
your coffee drink coffee
yeah little cup of coffee your battle
style you wash yourself you wash your
hair you get all dolled up things you
too one little bonus just one just went
out the window
exhale all the bad energy that you were
thinking about in the shadow whoever you
hate that day where we don't want to see
no take a lot of your life with that
exhale and the first 30 minutes 40
minutes a day they'll be almost creative
time you'll ever have in your life
you'll love it so much that you'll make
time for that creative domain I believe
it
as is you have a call at going you'll
cancel your spots on it before cuz you
get up at 5:00 because you fell in love
with a part of the day that you didn't
know existed and guess what there's only
one person is that you oh my god it's
the spookiest [ __ ] thing
haha when you wake up at 4:30 but you
set the timer for your coffee for 4:15
then you get up you get up at 4:15 when
I believe it but I first started this
process which is writing a blog no
matter what yeah I'm a Mormon
yeah on MySpace when this started I knew
I was dead I knew I had to do something
so worst case scenario I know plenty of
comedy writers but it just got awful
yeah I knew I
right so on Mondays I started writing a
blog and I would force myself on Mondays
I would write it but I have a stubborn
pairing at the day afterwards and a
notebook oh wow Oh week so how I did it
was I get up at 4:30 and drink a little
bit of coffee I'd smoke a bong hit I'd
make notes cuz then I'd walk across the
street at 5 a.m. and walking to the YMCA
with my mind on fire ok this is the [ __ ]
and how would you work out I don't drop
this whole workout listen to you yeah oh
oh [ __ ] where's the lighter I'm not a
head I'm so into this at 5:00 in the
morning when your mind is on a sativa
maybe 2 or 3 buckets - mother you were
supposed to do yeah Canessa Teva
actually makes you 400 pounds get up put
flip-flops on put a bathing suit on put
a hooded sweatshirt on I want a t-shirt
and I would go across the street I would
[ __ ] hang up my jacket I'm gonna have
a child and the first thing I would do
is I would go on the steam room and
throw some eucalyptus in that
[ __ ] and they'd say don't put
the hose on the thermometer listen to me
I would bury the hose into the cold
water I would make that room go down to
3,000 [ __ ] degrees you'll cook a
turkey in there and I put the eucalyptus
in there and it would open me to [ __ ] up
all that phlegm and all that [ __ ] my
Luke yeah you have in your lungs you
just start spitting it out by the chunks
and it would pull the top core of your
skin out all those little minerals that
when you go to in-n-out burger and yeah
when you eat somebody's all yeah soul
even if you get brain then I would jump
listen to what I would do I would take
that same old put it all over me and
goings on the sauna and I would go back
and forth with that sativa mind on fire
just trying to remember the jokes in the
thought and then I touch that for my 20
minutes I run out into the pool the
heated pool but I do laps like 40
minutes I come in
I do a stay another song and wash my
[ __ ] and then walk back my wife
wouldn't get up to eight those days so I
get back over how six I gave me two
hours yeah by myself after exercise two
right and we don't know you can pull
this well I'm an old man I can't get up
heart attacks happen between 6 and 4
a.m. did you take naps sometimes but you
could get up at 4 and go to your spot at
night and stay up and say y'all I would
take a nap you're right I would take a
nap but I'd be so tired to go on hold it
happened that yeah but I would do that 5
days a week just to prepare myself to
write to give my I read one of those
books but like Spielberg or somebody and
they said to give yourself a window and
I know what a better window to force
myself to do two things I hate to do
exercise and right